let's continue and i'll talk more about
crazy democrats and you tell me
if this guy secretary department of
homeland
security secretary alejandro mayorkas
you tell me if this is the guy that
should be in charge of illegal
immigration or not we've got videotape
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action
could we play that again because he
couldn't possibly i mean he's a democrat
these are good people
lawful people people with good ideas he
couldn't the guy in charge of
immigration couldn't have
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action
wait sorry maybe my ear thing is not
right today let me get this in it
that can't be i couldn't maybe i didn't
hear one more time
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action did you get that did
you get that this is the guy in charge
of the border and he is basically saying
if you can figure out a way to get in
we ain't gonna boot you possibly not do
anything and maybe we'll even give you
some money uh if you figure out a way to
get in we're not going to put you how
insane is that let me read the quote one
more time unlawful presence in the
united states will alone not be a basis
for immigration
enforcement action
so to link this to the previous segment
for just one second bill maher barry
weiss you want to prove me wrong you
want to show me you're getting to the
end of the road
tweet about this today i dare ya i'll
retweet you tweet about this today that
this ridiculous buffoon in the oval
office appointed this guy mayorkus to be
in charge of our borders and now we are
literally saying if you are here
illegally
but you don't do anything bad we just
ain't gonna do anything about it that's
not how a country is run dare i quote
that orange guy who said without borders
you don't have a country well that's
pretty much where we're at at this point
so again what is it that democrats are
doing that is good what is it that these
liberals are doing they don't believe
that if you are here illegally that is
your break in the law right right then
and there and by the way there's nothing
anti-immigrant about this and there is
nothing racist about this or anything
else nations have borders that's how it
works every nation on earth has borders
what they do in those borders is up to
them i personally
would prefer not to live in a country
where the people in charge said oh if
you can just come here you can have all
of our stuff and all of the benefits and
by the way we'll let you vote right
these idiots in new york city they're
letting illegal immigrants vote you
think they might vote for more
government programs for them which will
take more from the legally tax-paying
citizens i mean do you see how the whole
game works man
these people are insane so
what do we do what do we do well why why
would it be that people would be insane
right like why would it so what what's
going on in their mind give the devil is
due so when when maorkis says this in
his mind he's saying well we want to be
somewhat nice to these people right like
some people got here one way or another
and maybe they had kids here and by the
way there are plenty of people who got
here illegally who end up being really
good citizens and get educations and
start businesses and work real hard and
all of those things so i'm not even
against any of those people as
individual human beings it's just simply
does a system work or not do police
actually do policing do border agents
actually guard the border just like
anything else
right like do you just let anyone walk
into your house and if you happen to
walk outside to pick up the newspaper
and the door is open so someone walks in
and creates a camp in your living room
do you just let them stay
but for some reason we do this odd thing
with our country so we really need to
think seriously about getting rid of the
democrats i'm sorry that's what it all
comes down to at this point and it ain't
because the republicans are so great but
they're not bat [ __ ] loony
you